in this tutorial you will learn what a
market basket analysis also called
association analysis is and how you can
easily calculate it and we'll get
started right away
let's say you have launched your own
online store for clothing your goal now
is to achieve the highest possible
turnover with your store in order to
achieve the highest possible turnover
you of course want every customer to buy
as much as possible one way to motivate
your customers to buy more products is
to suggest more products the big
question then is which product do i
suggest to the customer best this is
where market basket analysis comes into
play
what does market basket analysis do the
market basket analysis gives an answer
to the question how likely it is that a
customer will buy product a
if he or she already has product b in
the shopping cart therefore the market
basket analysis gives you an answer to
the question
which products or goods are often bought
together thus if a customer already has
pants and shoes in the shopping cart how
likely is it that this customer will
also buy a shirt or socks or a t-shirt
but now the question is what do i need
to calculate a market basket analysis
you need a list of past purchases in
which you can see which products were
bought together so you have the products
listed and each row is one transaction
or purchase to make this clearer let's
look at an example let's say that this
is your example data you have the
products jeans shirt jacket and shoes
each row is one transaction or a
purchase one means bought a product zero
means didn't buy the product so the
first person bought jeans shirt and
shoes if you use state adapt for the
calculation your data can also be in
this form so each row is a transaction
and the purchased products are simply
separated by a comma in order to get
results that we can also interpret let's
first calculate a market basket analysis
for this data in order to do this we go
to datadeb.net
you find the link in the video
description and you copy your data into
this table
these are of course very few cases but
as an example it should be enough
then you click on plus and on the tab
association analysis we just click on
all products now we can specify a
minimum support and the minimum
confidence we will go through what
support and confidence mean in a moment
here below you get the results table and
below the table you get an
interpretation of the results from the
first row we'll go through this step by
step now what is lhs rhs frequency
support confidence and what is the lift
for this example data data dab has given
us these association rules each row in
this table is one association rule the
association rules are in the form
if the products under left hand side are
present in a transaction then products
under right hand side are also present
with some probability
frequency tells us how often the
products on the left hand side and right
hand side occur in a transaction so in
our case how often does shirt and shoes
occur in a transaction so let's just
count through in how many transactions
both occur
one two three four five six seven eight
so the frequency is eight in a
transactions shirt and shoes occur
together
support tells us what percentage of all
transactions that is
or in other words how likely it is that
shirt and shoes occur in a transaction
so we just divide the frequency by the
number of all transactions we have 19
transactions in total so we get 8
divided by 19 which is equal to 0.42
therefore the probability of shirt and
shoes occurring in a transaction
together is 42
confidence now tells us if the products
on the left hand side occur in an order
how likely it is that the products on
the right hand side are then also in the
shopping cart in our example this means
how likely is it that if shirt occurs in
the shopping cart then shoes will also
be in the shopping cart we can calculate
this by dividing the frequency of shirt
and shoes by the frequency of shirt
and finally the lift the lift indicates
the factor by which the probability of
buying the products on the right hand
side increases
if the products on the left hand side
have already been bought so let's look
at our example again
if the product shirt is in a shopping
cart it is
1.27 times more likely that shoes will
be purchased than if the product shirt
is not in the shopping cart if you need
support with the market basket analysis
or you need an individual solution just
contact us we can help you for sure and
finally a critical note about the market
basket analysis let's say your market
basket analysis shows that if a person
buys a pair of pants and shoes
there is a high probability that he or
she will also buy a shirt now you
suggest a shirt to all customers who buy
pants and shoes by doing this you
increase the probability that the shirt
will be bought under this condition and
a further market basket analysis will be
falsified
i hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time
you